so I'm Sarah Kelly I'm a data scientist
with the American institutes for
research where I work on a wide variety
of data science projects most focusing
on understanding innovation in the
nanotechnology space and working with
patent data and this is my co-author and
evidently twin sister Claire Kelly hi
everybody I'm Claire I'm also a data
scientist at the American institutes for
research my workflows focuses mostly on
data pipelining and machine learning in
the healthcare space so I'm interested
in taking a break from my general work
on healthcare availability and access to
work on this project about patent
citations okay I should have practice
this first
lovely helper here how do I go there we
go next slide okay
so what we're going to be talking about
today is patent citations so if some of
you are thinking that sounds like the
most boring topic in the world let me
try to tell you why we might be
interested in patent citations so for
those of you who are not familiar with
the patent space much like academic
articles which reference previous
articles on whose work they build patent
applications also cite also cite
previous patents whose innovation and
ideas they are building on these
citations are important to the inventors
because if you don't cite the correct
patents that can impede the approval of
your patent they're important to the
examiner of patents who determine if a
patent should be approved or not because
they need to see that the patent is
different enough from the other patents
in its space to be worthy of its own
separate pact and finally they're also
interesting on an academic level because
they help us understand the kind of flow
of innovation and where the innovations
that are leading to a lot of other
innovations are coming from which is
something that a lot of people in the
sort of science scientific and science
funding communities are very interested
in so there's a reasonable amount of
existing research on this there's a lot
of kind of black box applications built
by companies to help their own inventors
or to sell to inventors to help them
figure out their path citations and this
a resaurant of academic work in this
area to focusing on kind of two main
different approaches the first is kind
of a network based approach which looks
at who looked at kind of the the author
of a patent their affiliations
and uses that to predict whether their
patent will be cited by another patent
so for example an inventor at a very
well-known company and an inventor who
is widely cited and sort of considered
an innovator in their space we would
expect is more likely to be cited than
you know Joe working out of his garage
in Kansas City so these models kind of
focus on the relationships the existing
thank you the existing relationships
between patents and their citations
there are also sort of natural language
processing based approaches which try to
look for similarities in the core
concepts of patents with the idea that
patents are going to be more likely to
site earlier patents that talk about
similar ideas and even that use the same
language because it's pretty well known
at this stage that patents are more
likely to cite other patents that come
from the same kind of sub discipline and
so use the same kind of terminology than
those that come from they may be equally
related but use a slightly different set
of terms and I kind of talked about that
already
a lot of the existing approaches use
also take advantage of keyword search so
one of the things we were interested in
here is seeing if we could generalize
this to not require any human input so
not in the sense that the inventor
wouldn't have any input to their patent
because we're not quite that advanced
yet but in the sense that the search
itself wouldn't rely on a keyword
strategy and I like many of the current
the existing approaches do one of the
big problems with the keyword strategy
is it it leads to this within field bias
so if I was to write a patent and I know
my own subfield very well I will be
using keywords that match two other
people within my subfield but I might be
missing the keywords that match better
to similar patterns in other subgenres
and so it leads to this compounding
problem where all the patents in one
field save each other in a sort of
circle pattern and the arts hiding
relevant research from without that
sub-discipline which also has
implications for innovation because we
know that more cross-discipline kind of
cross-pollination of ideas is productive
for coming up with those really game
changing innovations alright so we
wanted to provide you a couple of
examples so you know what we're talking
about
obviously the text of a patent is very
long in this example we're focusing on
the titles and abstracts of some patents
within the nanotechnology space don't
worry if you don't know anything about
nanotechnology there won't be a quiz so
for example on this slide you see the
title of a patent and this patent
proposes to talk about methods for
arranging nanoscopic elements within
networks fabrics and films and on the
right hand side of the screen we have
three possible options that we can
choose to cite so if everyone takes a
second read through those candidate
options we're going to talk about which
one you think we should cite and there
will be a quiz so should we choose
option one golf balls having a
low-mileage HNP layer and high modulus
hnp layer or candidate two controlled
patterning and growth of single wall and
multi-walled carbon nanotubes or should
we choose option three nano crystalline
ceramic materials reinforced with single
wall carbon nanotubes so we're going to
take a vote surfer and take a second put
your thinking caps on who thinks we
should choose candidate one is the
appropriate pattern to cite to people
who thinks we should choose candidate to
some more people and what about
candidate three okay so that seems to
win by popular opinion the answer is in
fact candidate two controlled patterning
and growth of single wall and
multi-walled carbon nanotubes why who
chose carbon two and wants to tell me
why they thought that was a good idea
yeah you're really getting at the key of
our method here it's a niche word so
even without knowing the contest I know
nothing about nanotechnology I assume
most the rest of you do too we know that
a word that is very rare and appears in
both patterns is a stronger indicator of
relatedness than matching less important
words how hard was that easier easy
medium hard probably relatively hard
right we're trying to make a judgment
based on only a couple of words so what
have we had more information I'm not
going to flick you with reading this out
but if ever it takes a second read
through this abstract we're going to
talk about how to match this by the
abstract as well
so this is even worth to read them a
documentation of stock all right so
that's the abstract to go with the same
patent and now we have two other
candidate abstracts that we're going to
think about which it might be related to
so this is the first candidate
all right everyone falling asleep okay
next one this one shorter I promise
okay so again let's vote who thinks that
this the patent is most related to
candidate one minority opinion and who
thinks most related to candidate 2 all
right majority vote for no idea
apparently and a few brave people that
wrote voted for candidate one were
correct the reason that we're having as
humans more difficulty with this is as
the language gets more complex and the
abstracts get longer we tend to get lost
into details one of the possible
applications of this does this whole
project is to help out research
scientists who are doing the same thing
you just did and having their eyes glaze
over as they read through a
nanotechnology jargon over and over
again this is I have to say one instance
in which I have to admit my sister was
right I thought that identifying
patterns based on the text of titles
would be more accurate focused titles
provide a more focused look at what the
patents about it turns out actually
taking into account both the abstract
down the title is more accurate okay
so to move on to the fun tech stuff for
this project we use mostly Google based
infrastructure we're using Google
compute instances for all the
calculation steps we're using Google
bigquery to store the data and Google's
cloud storage as an intermediary for
storing files one of the big struggles
within the text processing space and
particularly to do with this project is
simply the volume of information we have
so the US government provides patent
data in bulk in XML files this is
helpful to nobody and so a big part of
this project was as collecting and
aggregating those XML files parsing them
into a flat format and then storing and
dealing with all the text it could it's
project we initially looked at about
250,000 patents which if you imagine how
dense the text and how long the text of
some of these patents can be ends up
being quite a big data problem so there
are a lot of times there are a lot more
than a quarter million patents so today
we're just focusing on patterns in the
nanotechnology space and the way we did
that we have filtered the all of the
available patents focusing on
only patents at me kind of a complicated
keyword criteria for nanotechnology if
anyone's interested in the details of
that ask me after and I can link you to
the paper that we use to develop our
sort of limiting strategy okay so the
first thing we're going to touch very
briefly on that we ended up not using
for our results but explored first as
this is a pretty common approach in this
area are a keyword and topic modeling
based approaches so the idea with topic
modeling is that we can divide our
patents into separate topics and then
really narrow our search space so we
divide our quarter-million problems into
200 different topics and then we only
need to look within a topic for possible
candidates to be cited
now that sounds really nice in theory in
practice it doesn't work so well so oh
if we look first at the talk of modeling
which is second on the slide but if we
look at first topic modeling we are
evaluating this simply basically based
on the percentage of citations that are
within that topic so obviously if we
only have ten topics we're going to have
more citations within with more within
topic citations in fact we expect if the
citations were distributed randomly we'd
expect to have 10% of the citations from
within that topic in fact we find that
if we look at the combined text of the
patent and abstract which tends to be
the most accurate method we have about
25% of the citations are within topic so
the topic is telling us something but
they're not discrete enough that we can
consider only topics consider only
patents within a single topic as our
search space and as we increase the
number of topics which makes this
technique more useful for narrowing the
search space we decrease obviously the
number of patents that's the percentage
of citations that are within those
topics we kind of hit the optimal level
was 40 topics where we had the kind of
of the the it's narrowed to space enough
to do more complex things if one wanted
still had a reasonable percentage of the
patents within the topic but even that
is not not good enough to really use in
practice and if we compare this with
keyword search approaches in 3 we looked
at nanotubes DNA and graphene and if you
look at topics defined by the presence
of those keywords you'll see that for
some like nanotubes you've got a
slightly higher that that field tends to
be more condensed with more of our
citations have it ones containing the
same keyword but even that isn't looking
so promising as a way to limit our
search space so we're really focusing on
building approach to an approach that
can be used across the whole set of
nanotechnology patents not just within
one particular area so the first
approach we're going to discuss is a
cosine similarity based approach so this
is a pure natural language processing
approach this doesn't consider at all
the existing citations of the patent the
number of citations to a given patent
all we care about is the similarity
between the language used in the two
patents so I'm going to assume that some
people are probably very familiar with
this kind of measure and other people
are not so I'm going to kind of go into
some detail about how it works and
hopefully not bore everybody too
terribly so the as I just mentioned this
approach is based on just the language
which has some advantages because it
doesn't perpetuate existing issues or
biases within citation patterns because
citation patterns because it doesn't
fever more heavily cited patents or
patents from well-known companies over
any other patents it just faces it on
the language similarity but also as a
disadvantages in terms of if there it
will be very vulnerable to with their
different and different kind of
linguistic patterns between fields it's
not necessarily going to pick up very
well on those similarities I mean there
are a couple of approaches we could use
relating to word embeddings that might
help with some of those issues that we
didn't get a chance to explore for this
presentation so the way this cosine
similarity model works is first we're
converting
our first we're converting the words in
this case the combined text of the title
and abstract of the patent to a death
based representation so to start with
that we are converting our documents to
a bag of words representation and then
we're counting the frequency of each
term in a given document so this is the
sort of term frequency part of the term
frequency inverse document frequency
that we're building up to so we're
representing each document as a sparse
vector of term counts so how many
appearances of the word nanotube DNA
graphing across the entire vocabulary of
the whole of the whole corporate all of
the patent data that we have so that's a
very large very sparse matrix there of
size number of documents times length of
the vocabulary hopefully that's
relatively easy for people to envision
however as our very clever
question answerer earlier in the session
pointed out some words are more helpful
than others we would we gain a lot more
information from knowing that a patent
mentions nanotubes than that has the
word V in it patents that both have
nanotubes are more similar than pacts
that both have V in them hopefully
that's relatively intuitive so as well
as considering the term frequency we
want to consider the inverse document
frequency so that is in our little
equation here is the a where we're going
to divide by the number of documents
that contain that that term adding one
of course we don't have a division a
zero division error if we have a term
that's not in the corpora and this leads
us to our term frequency inverse
document frequency measure which is the
term frequency in that document
multiplied by the inverse document
frequency of that term so what this
basically does is it favors rare terms
over common terms based on that kind of
intuition that we discussed earlier
about the more unusual terms telling us
more about the similarity of documents
than the
more common terms so we also if you if
you even pay attention to the math here
we also don't want longer documents to
be favored because if we just consider
the term frequency then longer documents
will have on average or higher frequency
across all terms so we'll be saying in
general that longer documents are a
better match new shorter documents now
there's no real empirical reason why we
would want to do that so we're going to
normalize within a row to normalize our
matrix in a row wise fashion and so that
we're basically getting the fraction of
words in the document that are that
particular word rather than the raw
frequency so our Python implementation
of this we use Jensen which has some
very nicely optimized code to do this
much faster than my handwritten code did
that was slightly demoralizing actually
hey where we create that term frequency
inverse document frequency matrix and
then we score in this first chunk here
over point oh yes okay where we create
the we create a dictionary and use that
to create a term frequency inverse
document frequency model and then we in
our second chunk here we score a sample
of 2,000 patents that we're interested
in we school them based on their
similarity to all of the other paths in
the space and we end up predicting the
20 most similar paths so if we predict
that if we predict the 20 most similar
patterns based on just this cosine
similarity approach that is that those
20 most similar patents includes on
average 10 percent of the patents actual
citations so nowhere close to what
represent accuracy but that's a
reasonable start for something that is
very easy to implement and requires no
kind of domain knowledge or extra
pre-processing whatsoever so so this is
this rope your natural language
processing based approach and we're
interested in supplementing this in
next step with an approach that
considers the existing citations of the
patents alright so one of the problems
in addition to identifying appropriate
citations is using the information that
the existing citations give to make our
process even better so in this data set
we know what every patent nanotechnology
patent since 2001 has cited and we
should be able to use that information
to help us when we have a new paper
check whether our citations are
sufficient and recommend additional new
citations that we haven't considered
so recommendation engines have been
something that's been gaining popularity
in industry for example I'm sure
everyone's seen on Amazon on Netflix you
have the customers you might also like
section which is basically the
representation of this matrix
factorization model in which we look at
previous user product pairs or in this
case previous patent citation pairs and
use that to suggest novel citations so
brief background on matrix factorization
basically we consider the data
representatives and matrix where each
row represents a patents and each column
represents the which patents excited
this is obviously a large matrix right
if we have 250,000 patents it's a
250,000 by 250,000 matrix which makes
nobody happy the idea behind this is to
decompose it into a set of latent
factors if your statistician you call
them latent factors is here this is the
decomposition we talked about in the
factorization pot there are not unknown
number of latent factors so going back
to the problem we had with topic
modeling we don't know how many distinct
groups of patents there are and the best
way to tell that is by in our parameter
search so we're going to start with the
40 latent factors that we decided with
best based on the topic modeling but
that's sort of the art part of data
science rather than the science part of
data science so in this case we're
considering the decomposition of
preference matrix R into a vector X and
a vector Y where the X represents the
latent features of a patent for example
you might consider this is how closely
related the patent is to graphing
technology or another latent feature
might be patents that are closely
related to electrical conductivity say
similarly there's a vector Y which
describes how closely or how likely each
patent is to cite that particular topic
both of these vectors are unknown and
are initialized at random when we start
the algorithm
all right so initially we attempted to
evaluate this and numpy because the
matrix mass isn't actually all that
complicated but this quickly leads to an
out of memory error so we turn to SPARC
to handle the distribution of this
across several machines in order to
avoid that out of memory error
luckily ml live has some very friendly
matrix factorization implementations and
the about six lines of code you see
they're actually completely runs a
implicit matrix factorization model
basically the key here is we're setting
the rank so that's the number of latent
factors the number of iterations will
allow and a confidence factor then you
train your model right there
it's important to note that we are
considering this as an implicit model
versus an explicit model so for matrix
factorization models we have two main
types implicit are typically used where
your data represents observed behavior
so in this case each patent has the
observed behavior of having cited
another patent much like in the more
typical commercial sense a user would
have had the observed behavior of having
purchased a product the other method of
matrix factorization relies on explicit
preferences which is where the user
makes a rating for each object obviously
the patent can't rate a citation so we
opted for the implicit method the next
challenge here was parameter selection
so the matrix factorization is evaluated
with an alternating least squares
methodology so you'll see that in the
literature at ALS
basically we alternate as the name might
suggest between fixing the latent
factors for the likelihood of citation
and the latent factors for the group
membership so first you fix the vector X
and you find optimum value for Y then
you fix the Y while you find the best
value for X and you alternate until you
until you're making either small
incremental improvements or you've
reached the maximum number of iterations
in terms of parameter optimization we
did this with a combination of prior
knowledge so that's the picking for T
latent factors based on the topic
modeling and a grid search through the
other parameters obviously using it we
split into a training and a test set and
we're trying to minimize the mean
squared error for the test set so in
this model is very different from the
cosine similarity and that it doesn't
take the language into account at all so
we went from a model where we're caring
only about the language to a model where
we're only caring about previous
citations and as we discussed before
this has some of the limitations that
human work does as well so this means
that we're perpetuating rather than
preventing that in field bias it's also
less intuitive to explain so if you were
to provide this as a service this is
coming closer to those black box back
black box methodologies than the cosine
similarity in addition everyone is
familiar with the cold start problem
recommendation engines in general don't
do well for cases with little known
information so when we have a new patent
if you only have a couple of citations
it's difficult for the model to know
what other patents you should cite so we
see this more as an extension of
existing work so this is a good way for
somebody you could put in a patent that
you'd written with your existing
citations and this might recommend to
use some new citations that based on the
patterns of other authors you should
also have looked at so this is more an
extension than a replacement it's also
hard to empirically evaluate the quality
of new recommendations in commercial
recommender systems we often solve this
problem with a/b testing so if you own
Amazon you can tweak the parameters and
see who clicks more on your
recommendations with your patent it's a
little hard to tweak the parameters
and see which were the better citations
because that's something that has to be
evaluated manually which is obviously
something as data scientists we should
avoid however as a little sanity check
the two methods don't produce totally
disparate results the recommendations
from the cosine the top 20
recommendations from the cosine
similarity method and from the
recommendation approach have an overlap
of about twenty percent so about 20
percent of the patents recommended
through cosine similarity are also
recommended through the recommendation
engine which is a decent amount of
overlap so clearly some the same sort of
core relationships are being found at
least in some cases so our basic
conclusion and is that these offer
important opportunities to support human
citation choice for patents and we'd
like to extend it to eventually to
academic articles too because what
assure reviews are horrible oh but we're
still nowhere close to an automatic
system that won't require any human
input and can do this entirely
automatically does anyone have any
questions
so so near recommender system
aren't you recombining the factorize
matrices back right and then you're
doing cosine similarity once again is
that no okay so these are two separate
approaches so the cosine similarity
looks just at the language and that is
entirely separate from the matrix
factorization approach which is simply
looking at the possible decomposition of
the patent citation pair so it doesn't
consider the language at all okay but
aren't you trying to okay so when you
are trying to find the most the closest
patents right yeah
what measure are using so in the cosine
similarity we're measuring closeness by
similar language in the matrix
factorization model we're measuring
closeness by on citations to similar
patents the leading factor is right yes
okay got it
second question and maybe it's a
suggestion ago um since you're using an
evaluation criteria for your the first
method right basically how many actual
citations are there versus how many you
could predict right yeah couldn't you do
the same thing with your recommender
system yes you could but we didn't
consider that as the best evaluation
strategy because the strength of the
recommender system is it looks at your
existing citations and uses that to find
extensions to find ones that you
previously haven't cited so we're seeing
the strengths there as the ability to
recommend new things that you hadn't
already cited is going on so that's
supposed to we're supposed to be adding
more difference there in a sense and
cosine similarity we were looking at
getting to similarity okay great thank
you yeah
I have many questions so I'll prune it
down to just one now I got a little bit
lost at the end when he did the
factorization so one question I had was
you had these two latent partitioning
the matrices into two different factory
units two matrices yes and I wasn't
clear on the connection between that and
the citations that you're generating
there's a new citations so okay it's a
bit hard to explain because both
accesses of our matrices end up being
citations so the idea behind this is
that you are trying to find latent
factors for all the columns so in our
case our columns would be which patents
were cited by a particular patent and
also latent factors among the rows so
we're decomposing this into a likelihood
of citing a given patent so the latent
citation features is what we're trying
to call that vector and the other vector
is similarity among patents so if your
patent cites similar patents to my
patent there probably are probably
sharing one of those latent patent
similarity features so the resultant
matrix you get is actually showing the
the likelihood of that you should be
citing something else yes and so you can
look at because we chose to use this as
an extension rather than a replacement
we're looking at what are the most
recommended patents that you didn't
already sight so you can imagine this
says other patents like you cited these
different patents just like the sort of
Amazon one thank you okay then the
second question I had is you did you
actually evaluate quantitatively the
result I didn't see a slide talking
about quantitative evaluation metrics
for this particular part so we didn't
evaluate as I think we mentioned earlier
we didn't evaluate the recommender
system quantitatively because it has
that because the goal of that is to
provide an extension to provide
additional patents to sites that's
difficult to evaluate quantitatively
without having someone look at those new
citations and see whether they were and
see how good they were so we didn't make
it to that step for this project yet
that would be the job of one of the
unfortunate research assistants
I was curious if you've thought about
combining the models yeah so going
forward I think one of the things we
want to look at is a sort of model
ensembles so that's something that's
been really successful in a lot of the
national language processing field and I
feel like there's more we can get into
not just combining the cosine similarity
and the recommendations but there's
other methods that we could get into as
well bringing in that networking models
that we've talked about it's very
beginning which look at connections
between authors and institutions and I
think that would probably be the winning
solution the end would be one that took
into account waited a variety of waited
models there's been some successful work
where some author company topic models
that combine the kind of linguistic
approaches with information about the
authors and the companies they work for
both their reputation and their
connections to one another because
obviously a Microsoft inventor is more
likely to cite another Microsoft
inventor than an Apple inventor probably
any work losers there's one behind you
I'm kind of curious with the linguistic
similarities stuff how much a syncretic
styles of the author's themselves can
give you some false false readings I
mean obviously one researchers likely to
do a lot of things in the same field but
maybe you that you would because they
use the same sets of phrases you know
you get your get your authorship type
influences and I wonder if that would
also happen with people who were
collaborators yeah I think auto citation
is probably going to cause some
difficulty in the matrix factorization
approach we all know cliques of authors
who only fight each other and that will
create sort of false latent chapters
basically that represent membership in
this group rather than a true latent
factor and when it comes to the
linguistic analysis you there is that
same problem
I think that's mitigated somewhat by the
fact that we are taking a term frequency
approach here so the phrases so there's
more idiosyncratic phrases probably the
idiosyncratic words but I agree that
that's a problem and we should probably
quantitatively evaluate how many of your
own that's that's tricky that's really
interesting because you we want to look
at how many of your own patents are
getting recommended but how often but is
that right is that because you're
focused on one really specific niche
area so it makes a lot of sense that
you'd be patenting a new innovation
based on your old innovation so that's
actually a really interesting question
justice but an interesting question
we'll take that okay I have a question
or two yes for topic modeling which tool
provisions oh yeah Jennsen again which
are course LD LD i yeah maybe okay and
how how was the performance the training
performance the performance was pretty
good I mean this would I did not do put
any effort into optimizing that to go
quickly I just ran it with the the
different numbers of topics specified I
think it ran overall in about an hour on
the 250,000 patterns that we're focused
on so you I probably could have got it
to go faster if I put F into that but
for the purposes of this project that
would slide okay and for spark I think
matrix factorization you have used this
particular for this yep and so it's an
eight-core cluster it converged pretty
quickly less than ten minutes but one of
the advantages of the Google compute
environment and one of the reasons we
chose that is because you can scale your
clusters in run time so initially I had
four CPUs that wasn't working well
enough you can add in four more and it
goes faster then that's especially
important for the hyper parameter tuning
when you're running the model multiple
times to evaluate different parameters
or when your sister prints out the
results excessively and runs out of
space when you're in the middle of
running one of your models yes that do
good okay
any more questions okay thank you so
much awesome thank you
[Applause]